[Music]
so if you're a big bitcoin guy
right get peter schiff on board get me
to accept bitcoin
and you know you uh you accomplish a lot
so i initially sent a string of
three replies to uh elon musk
so my first reply was as an engineer you
should know the distinction
between a tangible element like gold and
a mathematical string of numbers
which is bitcoin that there's a huge
difference gold does not need miners to
power its existence
the laws of physics do that gold
provides owners with optionality
when you have gold you can do three
things with it you can use the gold
yourself
right as a conductor of electricity or
whatever you can improve the gold or i
can take the gold
and i can make some jewelry at it or i
can just hold on to it
now when i'm holding onto it i'm holding
it so that somebody in the future
could use it or improve it that is the
store of value
that gold has it is a metal that can be
used or improved
gold functioned as a currency as a money
as a media of exchange
for thousands of years just because
we're not using it now
doesn't mean it hasn't proven that it
can be used bitcoin has never been used
by any society but to say that it will
one day is nothing but pure speculation
i don't think people are saying that
anymore i i think i agree with you peter
but i don't think people are saying that
they're saying it's no longer
it was it could be used potentially
theoretically i think you can get a
vending machine the guy bought a pizza
whatever
i agree 100 but they're saying it's a
store of value
okay but here's the thing so if it's
never going to be used as a currency
then what the hell value does it have
that you're storing see what
and when i'm storing my gold right when
i'm not using my gold when i'm
melting down my gold and i have it in a
bar i am
storing that metal because somebody in
the future
is going to need that metal and if you
don't want to do it yourself
you can hold on to it until somebody
else wants to do it
right bitcoin you can't do any of that i
mean you can hold it
but you can improve it and you can't use
it and neither could the person who
eventually buys it from you
all you can do is hold on to it and hope
that somebody else wants to buy it
people don't get it and neither does
elon musk because he still doesn't see
gold as a medal and understand the
difference
between a actual medal and just a string
of numbers
on the internet then i addressed the
other part of his reply to me
having to do with an email confirming
ownership of gold
is not the same thing as gold right now
what what did he mean by that
well what musk was referring to is let's
say you buy gold
from a third party who does not deliver
it to you right like when you buy gold
from shift gold
we take your gold put in a box and send
it to your house so you actually get the
gold in your hand
what musk is talking about are
circumstances where
you buy gold but you don't actually get
sent the gold maybe you get an email
that says hey we just
you know you bought gold and we're
holding it for you and so you have an
email
and he says an email you know that says
you have gold is not the same thing as
actually having gold
and so the way i addressed that in my
reply
i tweeted an email confirming
gold ownership either from a private
vault
or a government is but a secondary layer
of trust
you can confirm this trust on your own
while bitcoin's
ostensible trust layer requires a
network of miners
spending five percent of the market
value of bitcoin
every year to do it for you right now
to expand on that because you know with
twitter you just have a short tweet
look if somebody sends me an email that
they're holding my gold
i own that gold right i can verify with
that third party
i can send somebody down there to look
at the vault
i can ask them to send me a photograph
what's the number of the bar
i there's a way to verify third party
ownership
of your gold right and you can always
take delivery of that gold at some
point in the future so let's say you had
a brokerage account and all you had was
common stocks and you had notes and you
had no
you had no um cash right you just said
common stocks
if you put the stocks in a margin
account right
you could just take that debit card and
and just start
buying stuff and it's like well i'm
using my ibm to buy a pair of socks
well technically no because the guy
that's selling you the socks is getting
dollars
a lot of people own stock
in tesla and a lot of people who own
that stock in fact
everybody who owns that stock they don't
have this tesla share certificates in
their hand
they have them in a brokerage account
and their broker sends them an email
that says you bought 100 shares of tesla
well is that not the same thing as
owning tesla
don't you still own it even if it's in
your brokerage account
and you don't have the certificate yes
you own it right
according to elon musk's own logic
you might as well own crypto than tesla
because if you have
tesla in your brokerage account you
don't really own it
of course you do this is all nonsense
and he's acting as if when you have
bitcoin
there's there you don't have to trust
anything yes you do i mean
every time you do a bitcoin transaction
the transaction has to be verified
the miners have to verify it that's why
the transactions take so long they're
not instantaneous
they could take hours because miners
around the world are verifying
these transactions and it's very
expensive in fact if you look at the
total cost
of verifying all the transactions it's
about five
percent of the total market cap of
bitcoin
i mean that is enormous but then in
another tweet
i went into his understanding of money
this is really where he displays
his lack of understanding because he
said money is data
right that's what he said money is just
data no it's not money is not data
money is an actual good
in and of itself money was an
improvement on barter because
instead of trading you know one
good for another you just traded goods
for
gold which was in of itself a good
so if you paid somebody in gold you were
paying them
with something of value in exchange for
the thing of value that they gave you
now they may not need the gold
meaning that maybe they're not a jeweler
or they're not a ship manufacturer right
they don't actually need the gold
but somebody needs the gold there's so
many things
that you can do with gold and that gold
came from the collision of two enormous
neutron stars and that happened perhaps
five billion years ago in our region of
the galaxy
and the neutron enrichment basically a
giant atom not a 56
neutron but 10 to the 56 neutrons or
something like that
coming together the shrapnel of which
produced the gold
it is actually the most useful metal of
all the metals on the periodic table